a grandmother from the Netherlands was
recently ordered to delete her
grandchildren's photos from facebook and
pinterest after her own daughter took
her to court because the grandma refused
to take down photos of her grandkids
they nude no they weren't nude they
don't describe the type of photos they
just say that the mom was just very
adamant about the fact that she just
didn't want her kids photos online
period and then the grandma she just
would net like she no matter after like
so many times of asking her and so many
arguments to the point where they
stopped talking they stop talking like a
year ago and then finally like the mom I
guess she just got so fed up that her
mom wasn't listening that she ended up
taking her to court yeah yeah so the
grandmother she was posting family
rivalry three grandchildren age fourteen
six and five take them off [ __ ] no my
grandchildren I do it I watch my
Facebook page I feel like it had to be
like the mom and then the mother-in-law
well really like her real mom it's her
real mom it's a real mom yeah yeah cuz
it does make more sense with the
mother-in-law rivalry yeah cuz like if
the parents own the kids and the grandma
owns the mom the grandma also own the
grandkids like to do whatever the [ __ ]
that's true it's like a super Barney the
healthy way of looking at it right it's
technically under 18 aren't they the
property of the the the highest order
you would be like so your dad could just
come over and take tae Kuk cuz here
that's what he does right now like he
just comes over and takes them and he
doesn't even tell you what like every
since I moved out every single pad that
I lived in my mom was demanding why I
never got an extra key made day of so
that she also has the key even when I
first when I first moved with her she's
like why do I have gos key
I'm like because that's her house yeah
I'm like maybe if I have my own place
and she moves in with me I might think
about giving you a key
but then yeah so she's already like
where's the Kia the only key she did
have though was like when you guys lived
in like the other plate like her
property whatever she had piece of that
right yeah and she would come in all the
time so when I first when I first got
like my condo and I moved out of house
for the first time ever you know I gave
my parents a key to be like here guys
you're wealthy your good son you're
welcome in my new crib right because her
mom is like my mom so but I used to tell
them like but please just text me call
me first cuz my dad would just come in
like he came in on multiple occasions
that I'd be like dad I could have been
naked I could have been masturbating on
the couch if that's one of the best
things about living alone is that you
can masturbate any booty oh yeah yeah
but like that could be I could be having
sex with my with my fake bull on the
coffee table on the coffee table and
like I don't want you to see that again
[Music]
so but then he was like alright fine I
get it I get it you know
he started nothing no then he started
coming in with a camera no I'm just
surprised no my mom you know I can't
feel like my mom was always kind of a
little mad that I even moved out ever
not still but when I first moved out
especially she was like she just didn't
want to go to my condo you know I'm
saying I could believe it it's like
right next to your other house it was
literally a block away yeah but she
still would like you know would never be
up there and then unless I was out of
town for like a weekend going on doing a
show at a college or whatever I come
back and there would be random pieces of
like furniture there that I my mom
thought would be cute in my god oh my
god how do you like a new shoe rack or
like a buck in like ceramic I don't know
period or some [ __ ] just in my kitchen
and your fake booty was all clean
[Laughter]
there's like a bow on it did a couple
fabric softeners on there and I remember
one time I was bending to my dad I was
like dad it's like man like I came home
it was just like weird Pelican in the
bathroom I'm like mom always buys he's
like tacky-ass things puts them in my
place and my dad's like I bought that
they're looking for so my mom's a big
fan of like natural wood [ __ ] so she was
always buying like when we used to live
in Monterey Park she would come home
yeah I should bring these like root
things that just so happen to have like
a flat spot and it goes into branches oh
you just sit right here and so she'd
bring all these weird like wood
sculpture no check this one out so we
went on a vacation to Taiwan for like
maybe a month like three weeks to a
month so we left the house looking one
way when we come back the whole bathroom
has been remodeled that we had no idea
that people were even going to be
entering our house so she was like I was
like well it's her house so I was
renting from her but she was like but
still a little heads up oh yeah she gave
me a little hint she's a hey I've ever
thought about remodeling the bathroom
I might no never that's not a hand baby
that's her giving me a hit I gotta go no
never and I think okay cool and the
discussion right we go to Taiwan we come
back and then we come into our bathroom
and there was a bathtub there and now
there's no batteries no bet it's just a
straight-up stand-up shower and then I'm
like wait I thought I said no so I asked
my mom issues at all it's because your
uncle was thinking about visiting and so
it would make it cuz he has a kind of an
injured leg could be easier for him to
take a shower and I'm like I don't think
my uncle's gonna stay with me he comes
visit anyways he ends up never even
visiting now she spent all that money
remodeling for that possibility yeah but
I honestly think it was probably she's
kicking it with their contractor homies
and they're like say like all you know
what's the newest thing right now
these little tiles so she probably
wanted to put that in the house dude but
the idea that I'm gonna go around to go
to the store I see a pelican on the wall
my son needs a pelican in his
i buy it i go into his house when he's
not home I put it up there I'm like
mm-hmm
yeah I think it's I think that's right
he was waiting for me to be like that
stuff coyote was that your dad yeah he
has a stuff cut it sounds like maybe
he's at the taxidermy and [ __ ] no here's
what is a stitch coyote in my parents
living room there's a stuffed coyote in
my pears legumes super lifelike it's for
sure it looks like a real [ __ ] dog no
it looks [ __ ] real I have people
coming to the house tonight yeah so my
mom just likes stuffed animals like but
like no a lot of stuffed animals but she
started buying more realistic looking
stuffed animals like little like kittens
that look like they're like perched than
[ __ ] but cartoony ish right and then she
had bought this like kind of like big
stuff to Tiger looking thing it didn't
look super real but you know it's like
more real than a stuffed animal so I was
leaving a show in Arizona or something
like that and I was going through the
airport and there was a store that sold
mainly like Native American jewelry and
all types of [ __ ] and there was this
dope
stuffed wolf coyote just on this rocking
chair and I'm like holy [ __ ] dude you're
literally your dad yeah he got a pelican
and you gotta know here's the thing I
don't have a history of liking pelicans
or ceramic birds my mom likes stuffed
animals well apparently dead is neither
cuz you thought it was your mom what you
listen to yourself well apparently your
dad doesn't have a history of Pelican
[ __ ] decoration either cuz he thought
it was your mom who but if that was your
mom about Apollo yeah winner so I buy
this stuffed wolf which was alive bro I
get expensive because it was either her
birthday or Mother's Day coming up and
there's like 18 her bucks for this thing
she tells your dad brought this I know
no but they are so I brought it and I
bought I think it got shipped over and
yeah and they loved it it's this well I
know your payers don't care about it cuz
I don't know what your house it was
underneath the coffee table with a bunch
of boxes no no no no it's there too
it says it's as a guard for like yeah I
think you missed them underneath a glass
coffee table brah you can still see
trying to hide it it looked like if they
loved that would have been on the couch
it would have been trust me that is she
likes it I hope you agree back he's
napping you see daddy trust me
yeah daddy that works anyway back to the
story so yeah what the hell the grandma
remember being sent to court about the
photos wrong yeah so the judge ruled in
the daughter's favor and ordered the
grandma to take down those photos and
also she will have to pay 50 euros for
each day photos are publicly available
on her social media account that's fair
or like the current photos that she
hasn't taken down but then for future
photos her daughter had asked to the
judge for a penalty of 250 euros per day
but then that the court ended up saying
that goes to excessive let's just keep
it a 15 yeah but yeah that's daughter
her mom's stubbornness but right I know
so I don't know and then because they
mentioned Facebook and pinchers and I'm
like yeah why is Pinterest it's huge
yeah but like posting your own personal
things that's kind of weird maybe old
people just use it wrong because if you
think grandma and you really like these
pictures just print them out and put on
her wall right yeah normal grandmas now
are younger it's mushy on grandma she
got a flex on her other grandma homeys
it may be my grandkids away cuter than
yours yeah look what I pinned on
Pinterest see if your baby's ours but
why is the daughter tripping that she
has photos of her grandkids on Facebook
that's just normal as far sounds like
they have a shitty relation I think so
it's more of a petty battle like these
kids I told you know listen to me you
never listen to me [ __ ] mom maybe
they're ugly oh yeah yeah the kids and
she doesn't what she's like moms I'll
stop putting my ugly kids out there I'm
trying to keep it under wraps
I think that makes sense like I hope it
going to the looks maybe yeah
please wait until you know till the nose
makes sense oh yeah so they so there
were they were reporting here that
usually the courts they wouldn't care
for like these like personal like purely
personal or household processing of data
because there's this thing called the
GDP our general data protection
regulation that was implemented in May
of 2018 which is a regulation in the EU
law on data protection and privacy in
the European Union and it pretty much
addresses the transfer of personal data
outside the EU areas and so the courts
were saying that because of the fact
that she's posting this publicly like
that's already like like breaking the
rules here like because there's no
consent from the parent entrusting and
they're under 18 because the news always
bears to children so for the amount of
days that she had the photos accessible
on her Facebook and Pinterest
it totaled up to a thousand euros as she
has said to pay that's a lot for Grandma
I know she I'm making no money well
maybe she is she's a young grandmother
or maybe she's like a grandma influencer
she want to be photos God don't don't
tell her her life maybe she's maybe has
left tuck maybe [ __ ] no I think she does
have a tick tock actually part of that
batty grandma the charger ass
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]